(locker shuts)
(engaging music)
- Aimee, you all right?
- I've been wanking all night.
I ate four packets of crumpets
and I think my clit might drop off.
But I know exactly what I want.
(playful music)
Not on the roses!
Got me queen, I win, win.
- No, you don't, you have
to get rid of the queen.
You lost, sorry.
- I still don't get this game.
My brother bought a girl
home once and she wore
a "Nine Inch Nails" tee-shirt and my mum
thought she worshiped Satan,
also she did a massive shit
in the toilet and my dad had
to break it up with a stick.
So don't do that either,
'cause first impressions count.
My auntie got eaten by wasps.
- What, she was stung to death?
- No, she was eaten.
Does he remind you of someone?
- Adam?
- No, I was thinking more
like a boy-old Ryan Gosling.
You know, he's probably gonna
be president or something.
- We don't have presidents
in this country, Aimee.
- You know top-heavy C's,
bit like a chip-chop.
- Okay, where is it?
- Oh I don't know, I just
sort of arrive places.
- Are you having a good time?
- I think so, not on the succulent!
- I love your outfit.
- Thank you.
- I mean he has been wearing
a lot of tracky bottoms
recently, but that's only
because he set his jeans on fire.
- What?
- He's got second-degree
burns on his thighs,
but he was blazed when it
happened so it only hurt a bit.
Last week I got chased by a fox
and Kyle threw a shoe at it.
It was so romantic.
Is this is a sex thing?
Has he got worms or something?
Is he giving them to me?
Am I riddled with worms?
(farts)
Oh.
- No, Aimee.
- I'm sorry, I'm really nervous.
Ugh, my parents are gonna kill me.
They barely got over the last party.
- Why'd you have another one then?
- Ruby and Olivia said they
couldn't do it at their houses.
Anyway, I love hosting.
(hand slaps)
My ham.
- Take these back for me.
Oh, and by the way I have some late fines.
- I like to be helpful.
Stevie's been doing extra study
for your stupid altitude scheme.
You're my date.
- Attitude scheme, Aimee.
- Yeah that's what I said.
- Yeah.
- Can you win me a giant pig?
- You were supposed to
be here three hours ago.
- I walked.
I'm really enjoying walking at the moment.
It's so evaporating.
- Invigorating?
- Yeah, that's what I said.
Let's do a mind map.
- What's that?
- Oh, it's just writing stuff down
but in a fun way that engages
all sides of your brain.
- You mean both sides?
- Yeah, all of them.
It's really good for hard decisions
like should I get a fringe, even though
mum says it will make my face look chubby?
Or, should I tell mum I hate her?
We could try a mind map.
Have you ever tried a mind map?
- I love mind maps.
- I don't really know what I
wanna do when I leave school,
but I always know when
I have a spot coming,
so maybe I'll become a facialist.
It says I should be a baker.
- Aims, I think it might be
banker, baker's not on there.
- I think I'm gonna stick with baker.
I do really like toast.
Did you know, you need like
sugar, and flour, and an oven
to bake, and you don't shove it all in.
You have to follow all these rules.
- Yeah, it's called a recipe.
- I baked a cake.
- What happened to this cake exactly?
- I was on the bus, and
a guy wanked on my leg,
and I got a bit of a shock,
and I smushed the cake.
Do you think it will stain?
I love these jeans.
- You have to report it.
- It's fine, they were only cheap.
- No, you've been assaulted.
- [Aimee] It's silly, I'm fine, honestly.
(Aimee cries)
- Aims, why you crying?
- Because I can't get on the bus.
- [Ola] So you can't get on the bus,
because you think that
man's gonna be on it again?
- No, it's more that he
had this really kind face.
I remember because he smiled at me,
and he didn't look like
some wanking psycho killer.
So it's like if he could do something
like that, than anyone could.
What are you doing here?
- Getting the bus.
We're all getting the bus.
♪ I used to be 17 ♪
- I'm angry that I'm not
very good at baking cakes
(glass shatters)
- [Both] Yes.
- Woo.
- Come on.
- [Maeve] Come on, Aimee.
- I'm angry that Steve
keeps trying so hard
to make things better but
he doesn't understand.
(glass shatters)
- Yes, come on!
(girls cheers)
- I'm angry that a horrible man ruined
my best jeans and nobody did anything,
and now I can't get on the fucking bus.
- Yes!
(girls cheer)
- This is amazing.
(girls cheer and yell)
I'm gonna keep smashing stuff.
- [Girls] Yeah.
(inspiring music)
(cheering)
- I'm dumping you, for her.
- Are you mental?
She's a slag.
- Yeah, you're right, but so am I.
- I'm not a slag.
- Me either, it just sounded good.
Is the lizard going to jail?
You're both wrong, it's my vagina.
I want a crumpet.
- Turrah, lad.
- See you later, pet.